hey what's up beautiful people welcome
to another episode of get close I am
your co-host Giovanna Antoinette Quan
and I'm Bart Quan the owner of Giovanna
Antoinette Quan you don't own [ __ ] then
how come when you leave this room I put
a leash on you
because I like it you do [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you free [ __ ] I'm a street [ __ ]
what nothing
are you okay never you need to put your
sunglasses back on when I'm around you I
don't know I just
I don't know what I feel okay well you
know what I'm feeling what do you feel
I'm feeling like talking about
some end-of-year wrap up some New Year's
resolutions if you have any well I see I
see what is that what does that look
like what is what do you hope 2023 looks
like for you
he can't laugh at me
you're about to say some Meathead [ __ ] I
want a bench this much I want to run
what is it
I really hope
I can start Jiu Jitsu next year why
would I laugh at that
because it's a meathead [ __ ] it's
something for pointing it out yeah some
people don't really care about but um I
really wanted to make it a goal
people don't care about it because they
don't understand how valuable it is okay
so I'll explain what Jiu Jitsu means to
me even though I've never done it okay
what do you mean you've never done it I
don't really do it oh like you don't
tell people you play the flute right you
don't see someone shredding on a guitar
and they're like hey I'm a musician too
bro yeah I played flute in the fifth
grade like no you didn't play flute you
I played put your mouth on a tube oh did
I a lot of them
um
so I don't count myself as have done
haven't done Jiu Jitsu right just like
if you can't bench 315 you don't work
out you know what I mean
so it's the same thing right so I don't
say I do Jiu Jitsu but I'm so stupid and
on top of stupid you're ugly
but I really on top of that you have
headphones on and your head's really
massive so you look even dumber damn it
just call me Princess Leia
um so what I love about Jiu Jitsu and
why I always preach something that I
don't practice that's amazing
is that I'm a huge fan of it right I'm a
huge fan of MMA
ever since it came out when I was and
why don't you do [ __ ] MMA and not
Jiu-Jitsu let me explain [ __ ] okay
[Laughter]
why is it so
so I love it I'm a huge fan of MMA right
which I've done MMA for like a year or
two [ __ ] I've done Muay Thai for like
three or four years I wrestled in high
school I've done wow Jitsu for a couple
of months so it sounds like you don't
know how to stick to [ __ ] so I've done a
little bit right you throw me in a room
with someone that has never done MMA
I'll whip his ass for sure someone that
is really dedicated like a year or two
that mma's gonna kill me okay
so but I've seen it with all of taika's
little colleagues with all his little
training Partners they [ __ ] wreck you
yeah so all
I understand it and I've done martial
arts for
at least six seven years very seriously
when I did kung fu
and so I understand the importance of it
and what I love about Jiu Jitsu so
building all that context of martial
arts what I love about jiu jitsu
is one it is
one of the few martial arts where you
can go a hundred percent intensity
without hurting someone Jiu Jitsu yes so
if I do 100 boxing with you we're
leaving with black eyes or whatever or
kickboxing we're living with bruised
shins whatever you're 100 Jiu Jitsu
because it's a grappling art we can go a
hundred percent
and we are can probably go 100 tomorrow
and then 100 the next day you know
because it's considered like the soft
art
is it yeah because I would get [ __ ]
mauled and wrecked but that's because
you don't know what you're doing yet but
once you get like you can get two blue
belts to go a hundred percent for 10
Rounds it was a hundred percent mean
because I've seen them [ __ ] explain
this [ __ ] exactly face yeah but that's
not a real damage it is I've seen broken
noses what are you talking about yeah
but it's not it's not real damage it's
not me kicking you in the face a hundred
percent
I see because you can tap at any time I
see so a jiu jitsu knockout is up to you
like the Jiu Jitsu knockout is what like
a rear naked choke or an arm bar it's up
to you how far you want to take it if
I'm doing kickboxing with you and your
shin comes this close I can't tap I have
to take it so every every uh intentional
damage is committed all the to the end
yeah whereas in Jiu Jitsu you can tap
whenever you know like hey I got a bum
shoulder yeah you know where that is if
you pull my shoulder my arm I'm gonna
tap like right away and then you have
communication cool so you know what I
mean so you can go 100 it's one of the
few Combat Sports you can go a hundred
percent
and be injury free or relatively
injury-free
so because of that what I like about
that is it is one of the most realistic
martial arts because you don't have to
turn it down for nobody
you know I mean you want to know what it
feels like for someone to resist you a
hundred percent we can go at it and you
can feel it without true damage versus
if I want to go against someone that
weighs 250 and I'm like I want to feel
what what your punch feels like 100 I
just have to get socks like that buddy
exactly right so because of that it's so
realistic it's so applicable and you can
really get that aggression now number
two because of the belt system there's
so many learning waves and curves and
also uh that with philosophies that you
learn that apply to life like they call
white belt you don't know [ __ ] right
like you try everything honeymoon phase
that goes right out the window when you
get your first stripe because then now
you're like oh [ __ ] the honeymoon phase
is over that one move that I learned now
everyone knows I know that one move and
they're killing me then you go down in
the dumps boom you get your Blue Bell
you're like oh [ __ ] hell yeah I know
some [ __ ] I can pretty much take out 95
of light belts out there like you feel
like the new king of the pack like when
Simba became a teenager but well you've
been referencing like guess what you
need a purple belt I found a whoop on
you and you're like oh [ __ ] I guess I
have a daddy right but then you work at
it hard you work out hard you become a
purple belt when you're a purple belt
you are like the leading
um almost like varsity
captain of the crooner until your daddy
you're like yeah yeah I'm a I'm like a
junior senior in high school what's up
freshman what's up sophomores right
you're like that and then this is where
people can lose the funk which is like
[ __ ] up in a purple belt for a long time
I think I know all the moves of the
black belt like on Tech on on paper on
paper but do I know how to apply am I
creative with them yeah but if you push
hard enough you get your brown belt and
you're like I literally know 90 of the
moves out there now yeah I am very close
to being a quote unquote Master right
and so you're in this brown but then
there's also Brown about Funk where
you're like [ __ ] black belt is right
there so far away it might how long is
it gonna take me is it taking another
one year or five years and what is the
difference and then this comes with my
character personal development comes
into play maybe your professor goes I
don't think you were a representative of
Jiu Jitsu yet you might have the you
might be good skilled skill wise but
maybe personality or not oh you don't
represent my school or maybe you can't
teach as good as you can practice or
maybe your your your your your
your game on your right side is better
than the game on your left you should be
ambidextrous you know and then finally
boom you get your black belt and then
it's almost as if you just entered into
a new pool of sharks starting all over
with black belt because now you got
first degree second degree third degree
and so like
this 10-year Journey I know it's going
to be 10 years you know so for me I'm
like
the longer I postpone it
the longer it's gonna take for me to get
it so for me I've been wanting to put
the time behind me but obviously with
this year we've seen a lot of crazy [ __ ]
happen that we've been dealing with on
the business end with on Titus and my
dad's in so like there's just so many
things up in the air and it was my plan
to really start Jiu Jitsu next year but
who knows if it'll happen but that's why
that's like a big New Year's resolution
because I literally think about it every
day you have the most meat head example
of why you want to do it but if I can
boil it down
um like you were saying it's something
that you can do like it's uh there's a
longevity to it
um it's very practical for just
practical defense
um and there's a lot of Life philosophy
in it that you really like and the
Practical part is a few episodes ago I
was talking about how it being the the
dad that I want to be being the warrior
the the you know like the type of man I
want to be
and I would love to have the feeling of
like I can protect my family against
99 of the world that feels dope I feel
like you could do that now you know no
maybe like 80 percent but like
um like I can go up against a skinny
like a buck 40 pound black belt and he
just whoops on me you know what I mean
like I would love to have the knowledge
where it defeats size
right now you have uh NFL like D1 player
could probably just run straight at me
and he weighs like 290 just [ __ ] runs
me over and I'm like time to say hi to
your new dad
you know so yeah what's his name so for
me probably Terrell Williams or
something so for me I would rather like
have that confidence of like yeah I
could defend my family against 99 of the
people out there and you just it you
walk life in a different way you know
it's almost as if like
a chicken has now like been given Eagle
wings the chicken is gonna be like
I'm like a little bit different today
than everyone else you know and then you
you almost become a different animal and
you see the world literally from a
different lens when you have new
capabilities yeah so I want to be there
like I I've
I
um that's something I want to strive for
and I just know that I have to put in
the time so I want to put the time
behind me instead of keeping the time in
front of me right right
and what's giving you now I know you
said life's crazy and all that [ __ ] I do
agree because I'm living it with you
um but if it's something that you've
been wanting to do and it's uh what
holds you back because you always make
time for everything I try to well one
thing that's really hard is the minute I
do Jiu Jitsu so like you only have so
much time right you got so I have my
physical training time I have my time
with you I have family time I have work
time what's my time with me we don't
have any time together yeah like we
don't go to the bed and they just go
straight to sleep we talk we watch each
other's take stock like even even the
five minutes here 30 minutes there it
adds up
right because then there's a couple
times where I go to the bed and hit the
sack oh
right I don't go um I go yes
yes no because if you want to live that
kind of schedule you know me I'm logic
boy I'll do that easy yeah I can pop out
of bed not say any cute nothings and go
to sleep and not say nothing cute yeah
yeah yeah no cute nothing it's [ __ ]
easy for me okay
so I have to waste my time on your ass
but um sure don't act like you don't
like it those I love it so those are the
different times that I have so in my
physical training time I would love for
my physical training to take about three
four hours a day I'll put [ __ ]
shooting in there I'll put my my pool
work in there I'll put Jiu Jitsu and
workouts in there but I don't have time
to dedicate that so right now like I did
I can only dedicate like an hour or two
Monday through Friday to physical
activity and because of all the um I can
only dedicate Monday through Friday
that's it that's cute there's not much
only two hours it's only 10 hours a week
I would love to dedicate like 20 hours a
week to physical activity
and uh you want it to be a part-time job
no I want to be at part-time having fun
and um
because of that
and we have like all these like new
series and initiatives that we don't
want to go in the barber gay channel I
need to train like three four or five
times a week yeah so I know if I
introduce Jujitsu yeah that's gonna drop
I'm taking away something else yeah
so that's that's one of your resolutions
or that's the one that's one of them and
then the other one that makes it hard
too is I I always feel like I want to do
Jiu Jitsu with you so I'm always trying
to time it or we can do it together it's
so [ __ ] CUNY why is it CUNY because I
love doing things with you would you
want to would you be happy if I did you
just by myself
um I don't know I don't think I care I
love doing stuff with you too I think
it'd be cutie to do together for sure
or what if I started doing it first and
then by the time you join I'm a blue
belt [ __ ] no
see
I also don't wanna have it I also I
don't want an unfair Advantage yeah no
[ __ ] no we're starting at the same time
[ __ ] get [ __ ] knew it I
[ __ ] knew you son of a [ __ ]
you just needed to ask the right way
dude you weren't asking the right
questions you know what I'm saying so
how can I do it first would you let me
do it first what don't say would I let
you would you let me I don't let you do
[ __ ] you are a free man you do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do but will I talk
[ __ ] yeah already signed up no you
didn't that's right there down the
street yeah right no you can't do it
without me we're [ __ ] doing it
together it's fine yeah
hey skinny yeah that's go ahead no other
ones
no other way uh resolution martial arts
I want to do no resolution more than
that yeah I don't do kickboxing and
there's all kinds of [ __ ] I want to do
um so that's one New Year's resolution
the second one is what we've been
alluding to so much during this year on
our podcast and Vlogs and stuff is
really building up our um like Financial
Freedom
you know and what's really cool is
there's so many uh
so much knowledge out there like
influencers that talk about it that have
done it now which is really really cool
like you got Alex hermosi Dave Ramsey uh
Ryan Pineda Grant Cardone there's all
these guys giving like all this uh men
from what's a mortgage there's all these
people that give all this information
out
so like and they show you how they've
done it what are some tools and things
to look for and so I think when you're
in your 20s you're in this big passion
hustle phase right and you have all the
time in the world yeah so you can't wait
to like commit more time and more times
what your passion is so fulfilling
rewarding
and what I realized is now that I'm in
my mid-30s mid honey I want to spend
late 30s there you go I want to spend
time with my family and so the time that
I was gonna commit to be receiving a
dollar
I can't commit as much time but then you
also still need the dollar right and so
I'm like now how can I put those efforts
into building up passive dollars that
would come in that allows me to so I've
been doing hella like
um research listening to podcasts
signing up for courses networking doing
the whole nine and a New Year's
resolution for next year for me is to
build up enough passive income where
um you don't have to work
or I can work like part-time you know
where like it supplements enough like a
a good chunk of it yeah yeah that's like
my those are like my only main two
decisions yeah nice and then I guess my
third one would be to start
um
bruh [ __ ] tending to those feet
never
um you said you were well I said you
sign up you sign up for a pedicure and
I'll go with you I literally told you
that like [ __ ] four years ago okay
these feet could carpet y'all I earned
these feet I hope you know these are
from badass feet just by not wearing
shoes what the [ __ ] are you talking
about you know I'll walk what what's so
hard about [ __ ] games walking on
concrete and building calluses like that
no you don't even have to walk on
concrete you can just walk on this
[ __ ] soft ass tile inside your house
and you're still gonna get them dude
you're not gonna get like this it's not
it's not crazy I could walk on like a
hot asphalt I can compare your feet to
homeless people feet they are by far
superior clearly there are the black
belts I know yeah that's what I'm trying
to get to that's what I'm trying to get
to you cannot get to that we are not
having sex what does it have to do with
anything a ton oh I don't want you
touching me with that
I don't caress your face with my feet no
but you caress my feet with your feet
yeah and you're cutting me up dude I'm
tired of it I'm tired of the scarring
I'll wear [ __ ] silk socks ew
[Laughter]
anyway what are we gonna say
um oh the third one is
um trying to establish a better
relationship with my mom I think
what does that look like well how do you
know it's better
um so I think like you know in the last
episode
or two episodes ago I was talking about
how I never really had a relationship
with my mom I always felt like I had a
manager a supervisor right that was a
nuts [ __ ] episode yeah and uh so I
had this distance
so I never had this feeling of like
wanting to be
um
like what's the word not intimate with
your mom but I hope not yeah just get
closer it's more personal vulnerable
they're like yeah yeah you know and then
like have like you know like son mom
time where you talk about things and and
be there for her you know like
emotionally and all that and I've been
no because I always try to keep her at a
distance
and now that we have a much better
understanding than
um relationship I want to be there for
her I want to be like like her Rock and
so she feels comfy you know that's CUNY
yeah and then kind of like because
ultimately I think everything I do
it's times two you know that's what you
do that's what happens as a dad when you
when you're a dad if you have a good
relationship with your mom it's just not
a good relationship with your mom it's
showing taika to how to have a good
relationship with his parents
you know if I'm like a dick to my mom
that's also what I'm showing taika so I
just like when I'm when you become a dad
like that's one thing that's always on
my mind all of my actions are times too
yeah so if I skip a workout it's not
just me it's like oh papa I just keep a
workout today oh I was tired then it's
like oh okay you can skip workouts when
you're tired you know I mean So like um
with taika like I just know that because
everything is times two like as quickly
as I can I wanted I've always wanted to
repair it with my mom but there's just
so much trauma that was hard but now if
I can be a good son to my mom I could
see that and he'll be a better grandson
to my mom I know be a better son to you
you know he has no choice I'm gonna
[ __ ] drill that kid yeah Asian style
no just kidding that's CUNY those are
some big well that's the only one that
really matters the Jiu Jitsu
[Laughter]
you're [ __ ] clown dude that's a cutie
one so you really won't let me Jiu Jitsu
from yourself are you serious so that
you can get a higher belt than me no why
you don't want to show up I'm like I'm
blue belt there's literally like there's
nothing you can do to even come close
and I'm just laughing the whole time
whooping your ass you wouldn't like you
wouldn't want that you know what I would
do what I would get I'd be like okay I
need to go train on my own I'd be taking
side private lessons so I could catch up
and whoop the [ __ ] ass
be like I'm gonna go get my nails done
you're gonna be like uh they always look
the same like you know that nail salon
has been giving you crazy cauliflower
that is a weird place
oh [ __ ] yeah I don't know maybe it's my
pillows maybe we need new pillows
those are some bikini resolutions
um is that that's it uh okay so for me
back in what are we in 2022 back in 2021
was a year that I was very what I would
call selfish where I was like
um I'm finally gonna tend to my own
needs I'm gonna look within see what it
is that I can do to be the best version
of myself
um and I was [ __ ] selfish like I had
my girls trips like I had you know I'm
like I'm gonna train for me like I'm
just gonna everything's for me that year
you know
um in so I'm calling it selfish but it
was very much in like uh like checking
in with you like it wasn't really
selfish you know what I'm saying it's
not irresponsible right yeah
and it's more selfish in intention
rather than consequence right yeah yes
absolutely
um because I just tend to I think I get
this from my mom but I tend to put like
everyone else's needs before mine
because I always just feel like
they're more important you know like I'd
rather just take care of them and then
if I have anything in the reserve then
I'll look at myself
so that was the first year I was like I
can't do that anymore like I and the
reason and the motivating factor for
that was which is funny and ironic uh I
was like I can't do that anymore because
then I'm not going to be a good mom for
taika which is funny because it goes
back to it going for someone else right
yes so then 20 20 21 I like hit all the
goals that I wanted to hit right like I
was really physically at a point where I
was really proud of myself very strong
physique
um really great relationships with my
girlfriends uh like everything I set out
to do I was like yes this is awesome
2022 AKA this year
um it was more of just like just
pursuing business more like it wasn't
anything as crazy as 2021 because I felt
like I really needed that
and then now going into 2023
um it's more so about being there for
taika to help him through all this [ __ ]
that he's kind of going through
um I don't really have a specific goal
for myself or I'm like this is what I
need to be doing like I want to continue
the 2021 Geo you know the one that's
pushing all all like levers of
everything that makes me me and like
putting those back up so the fitness the
the mental even the spiritual like I
really want to get back into I don't
know why I've been like so inclined to
do this right Jiu Jitsu no like DJ house
of worship yeah so I think I want to
just I think I want to get back again
and get in touch with like God or
something like I just feel like I like
my spirituality is they call it Sensei
it's very faint yeah um and I've never
had this yearning before isn't it
interesting
hello what makes you want to be
more in the like religion like you want
to go to church I don't know if I want
to go to church per se but I do like the
idea
um I've always been kind of spiritual
where I always feel like there is this
higher greater thing you know
um I don't know what it really is I
haven't really put my finger on it yet
just yet I kind of a CUNY idea you want
to hear it what
we're here now I mean that's what what
is kind of inviting yet what is it tell
me please share what if we do our own
church
keep going
well I'm gonna see it let me see it what
if what if we do our own church I don't
know what to say to that just yet so
I'll tell you what I like about that
could be like no but I want to hear more
about it so what I what I could tell you
about church that I like
um is one it's a weekly practice
right and then in the weekly practice
it's very introspective so it's
constantly like I think it gives people
a chance to slow down you know how like
there's that saying you know like
sometimes you need to slow down and
speed up so you can get so caught up in
like the the rat race yeah the hamster
wheel
that
you could be spinning your tires you're
not really moving far you know but then
having having because some of the most
um successful people are actually
religious
so you're like wait wait a second you're
telling me people that only work six
days a week can be more productive than
people that work seven days a week and
it's because they take that extra day to
reset so they're not spinning their
tires you know and so I think that
part's important the other part that I
really liked about church because I used
to play drums for church is the
community aspect and I think that's
really cool yeah
um and that's why like that's almost
like everything's built in you know like
oh oh we need a plumber that guy's a
plumber oh we need real estate agent
that guy's real estate agent oh we need
whatever everyone like hooks each other
up in the same community so it's like a
built-in Community yeah there's people
who you trust because you see them every
week yeah so for us
um I know you're not you're spiritual
but not so much religious but I'm like
what if we do our own church
and what if our own church is like the
same hike every week to a specific spot
and we go there and we talk to each
other about the week of like what we
liked what we didn't like and it's just
you and me and taika for sure we could
try something like that
um but then we'd have to treat it like
church where you there's this thing no
excuses you know that's the thing where
it's a little bit hard and the whole
Community aspect of it where you get to
learn from other people and see other
people's perspectives like you and not
part school yeah you and I spend so much
time together that
um we're obviously in a relationship for
a reason right because we just really
well we Gel really well
um we do see a lot of things eye to eye
is that what that was what is yours I
forgot I forgot even why I'm in this
relationship dude bro I was just pulling
[ __ ] out of my ass same
um so a lot of the things that we a lot
of the conclusions we make it's because
we're very similar but it's always good
to have an outside perspective or just
someone that's older wiser or younger
and just comes from a different
generation where they're seeing things
differently that really challenges your
ideas and I really do like that
seriously when you sign up for a gym
membership I mean that'll help for sure
the Church of iron and
before it became Barbara because it was
like I thought it was tight and you
didn't want me to yeah so happy we it
would have been so dope hell would have
been such a I mean we're not dead yet
there's still opportunity to do that
train at hell yeah go to hell I'm going
to hell tonight yeah
um
and then another thing that I was just
thinking about talking this out with you
the reason why I might feel like there's
this type of void is
like I'm I'm at an age now where like my
mom's a lot older your dad just passed
like
like I feel like the older generation is
just like
slowly going away you know and now we're
moving up and we're becoming the older
generation and I think yeah
um with that now comes the questions of
like
when I die what happens or like how am I
gonna die what am I gonna die like
like what how like what is it right like
there's just like we don't we don't know
what's gonna happen after that
um so I don't know if it's that where
now it's like
I'm older and I've entered this
different chapter in my life or if it's
I just don't feel like I'm
either like I might have a void in terms
of like just philosophical thought
because a lot of religion is very
philosophical like it does question a
lot of things and it does
um like set certain rules and like
religion does not question a lot of
things okay cool it doesn't question a
lot of things but it is very
philosophical it tells you what to think
is what religion does there's a there's
a but in a philosophical way
like what
um are you like talking specifically to
what religion yeah I know which one oh
you're saying all of them okay what are
you getting at they all have the same
structure
they all have some sort of Canon of
thought
that helps you get from this state
to this state yeah
right yeah so there's it's a very like
ten commandments or whatever whatever or
like a these precepts and Buddhism or
you know it's all the same thing yeah uh
maybe I'm looking at it that way what
are you looking at it maybe I'm thinking
about it philosophically but just taking
what is like being discussed and now
thinking about it and seeing what
applies and what sticks and what I like
about it
maybe that's what I'm looking at I think
that's the human perspective you
probably are looking for
so I uh are you saying I'm lonely
I Think You're Lonely I think a lonely
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I've been telling you
that for years
but like um I was listening but it's so
funny because then I'm with people and
I'm like oh I want to be by myself again
yeah like um one of our friends Hayden
Snyder he posted like this this uh
something about like uh The Root of
Happiness or something like that um and
I was like oh that's a that's a cool
thing like you said nothing or how to be
happy
and I didn't know what it was so I'm
gonna listen to it that was a podcast
I'm gonna listen to this on my drive I
click on it and it was a Sunday sermon
um and it was
um a pastor
talking about how you have to like put
in the work to become happy like
happiness isn't something that's a state
that is floating around you're like I
can't wait to it comes to me you have to
struggle to get happy of course right
but what was cool about it is it was a
recorded sermon it wasn't a podcast so
you hear the live like
um like a call and return you hear the
laughter the people talking and I think
that's the part that you miss where you
have like these standard cannons like
canons of thought and then he breaks it
down and he talks about it and like uh
his own daily life and then it relates
to people and you're like oh yeah that's
so true and then he talks about his
perspective about how like this this was
like I think I know what it is go ahead
I think I know what it is sorry to cut
you off but I think it just hit me what
it is good I'm glad um I don't think
it's the loneliness aspect of it I do
think you're lonely as [ __ ] but keep
going no I'm not I'm very I'm very
comfortable being by myself
um but I think what it really is is the
idea that
um obviously the afterlife that that's
something that's
it's been the [ __ ] question on every
human's mind like what happens when we
die right we don't know that
um so one of them is it's kind of like a
safeguard right you do good you're going
to heaven you do bad you go to hell and
essentially most of these this this this
thought is is displayed in pretty much
most religions just slightly different
right like in Buddhism if you're not
enlightened then you come like you come
back right frog is something else right
um so similar Concepts
um so that's part of it uh the other one
is the community aspect of it and the
values and and and not community in
terms of like
um like we all gather like that's
beautiful too but all Gathering every
week to like to to be better human
beings right like not that part of it
like that is that that's just a small
facet of it I think the bigger picture
for me is knowing that excuse me um that
we're all trying to strive for the same
thing which is to be a good person to to
be virtuous to
um believe in this greater good and
always strive to be
literally just a good person
like I feel like that's what religion
really does you know like it brings it's
supposed to bring people together
and I feel like right now I think maybe
it's more prevalent in my thoughts
because of just how and I don't know if
this is because of just what media is
doing or there's just social media just
described as the Church of iron we're
all trying to get better and stronger
yeah when we're strong in the mind I
mean strong on the body strong in the
mind yeah but it's not it's not so
straightforward right like it's
something that
um
or you're talking about striving to be
better
in Morality yes I see yes
that's what it is so you want a place
where you're training morality and you
hopefully like have a support team we're
all trying to strive for the same morals
yeah exactly I see and I know it's
flawed right because we're all human we
all have our baggage and our
interpretation of things or whatever but
I think
um I feel like as a society or maybe
it's the us or again it could just be
you know what I'm kind of engulfing
myself in terms of social media and when
I'm exposing myself to reading and
looking at where I feel like we've
really lost that sense of direction like
we're all just kind of like
grabbing for like straws here and not
really like
I don't know not really moving is that
something you want to do then you want
to go to church
I don't know if I want to go to church I
don't know if I'm like there yet because
you also want the community aspect of
like Hey we're all of us we're doing
this right yeah I don't know if I want
that just yet it's just something that
I've been thinking about more and more
and I think I talked to you about it in
the car I'm not sure
what sparked it and the only thing I can
really
bring it back to is just kind of what
the world feels like these days it just
feels like
um a lot of negative dark shadowy [ __ ]
is everywhere
you know what I mean yeah like it just
feels like everything is corrupt and
everything is so like evil
you know like like there's all these
conspiracies about covid and why that
happened you know and like fauci and his
daughter and all this and like they're
in cahoots with so and so and now it's
like uh the Balenciaga thing and all of
Hollywood is [ __ ] uh like [ __ ]
pedophiles and sex traffickers and
you're just like what the [ __ ] is going
on like where is the decency here like
where is where's the light like where
are the people doing positive things
like we don't get to hear about any of
that I see so it just feels like
social media if real life is a
reflection of social media it feels like
it's a Gotham City yeah it's Darkness
everywhere corruption everywhere yeah I
get you it feels crazy like like this
country is gonna invade you and this
other country's bringing in drugs here
and then they're [ __ ] publicly
hanging over here and they're like
[ __ ] taking women's rights away and
you're just like holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is going on like is it really like this
it definitely does uh through the last
couple of years
through it definitely feels like that it
feels like there's so much so much
ulterior motives yeah and it also seems
like there's a lot of silencing and then
there's a lot of
truth that is trying to be exposed
um but who also knows if it's the real
truth right and it just feels very like
untrustworthy yeah like it almost feels
so far from
um
like you know like the famous
presidential speeches where like JFK was
like ask not what the country could do
for you but what you can do for the
country yeah and it's some it's a line
that like both parties understand can
get behind and it almost feels like the
presidency regardless of his political
views is above both parties and really
trying to unite yeah versus now it feels
like whichever president is elected is
only fighting for that party and not for
the greater Nation yeah and it doesn't
feel like we have
it feels like instead of striving for
Morality it feels like let's convince
you convince each other which morality
is better yeah and it just feels so
divisive
um and everything just feels so unsafe
and like that's why I think coming to
Vegas too felt so nice because it it
still felt like a community you know
where every everywhere else I had been
I'm like holy [ __ ] everything just feels
so like torn apart when we first moved
here what was it 2019 no no 2020 no
that's only 21. you move we moved in the
middle of the pandemic 2020. we've been
here for you're right 20 20. you're
right
um and I remember at that time
remember when like I when I brought
tiger to our Park in LA
our HOA Park so we pay money to for that
part yeah we don't have a gate so people
can come in but it's our park and I
remember at that time when people were
still trying to figure [ __ ] out with
that like this is toilet paper shortage
phase people no more than two steaks per
family phase it was like really
heightened I remember taking to the park
and then
um the guys like uh some other dad was
like where's his mask
and I'm like what do you mean we're
outside he goes he can't play it unless
he has a mask and I'm like do you even
live here and he goes no
so I was just like you're playing
at our park
and you're trying to put your rules on
me for me it's irregardless of what side
you are on the vaccine or covet or
whatever the moral that I'm having a
hard time understanding is how can you
intrude into my country or my territory
and try to place your rules on me you
know that'd be the same thing as if he
came into my HOA Park and he's his son
doesn't have a mask and he's telling to
tell me to take my son's mask off it's
the same [ __ ] you know so I was just
like what the [ __ ] this is so weird so I
just took I didn't want to like end up
beating his ass so I just took type and
we went home because I don't even want
to deal with it
when I first come to Vegas you go to the
park and the height of the pandemic
still
half the kids have masks on half the
kids don't half the kids half the
parents have masks on half the parents
don't and I was just like
I think this is how it's supposed to be
yeah you have your own pretty beautiful
you have your own personal beliefs I
remember and you coexist right yeah and
I remember being at the park like
almost like
um it was like watching like a deer
breastfeed its kids like it was just
such a beautiful moment
ha
[Laughter]
you know what I mean
what the [ __ ] it was like watching like
so you watched a baby rhino like coming
out of the mom's vagina and then like a
Tears like coming out I was like it was
very yeah it felt really nice like I was
like
is this Zion is this like the promised
land that we're all supposed to go to
yeah yeah because everyone obviously you
can clearly tell like who's like how you
feel about things
and we're co-existing yeah I'm like this
is really that's Humanity dude cool yeah
I'm like because this is what I remember
of the 90s
where people are republican or democrat
or whatever and then they get along they
just have different views on things and
they're not trying to force each other
to believe in things obviously you want
to share some stuff
but I'm like this is what I was used to
yeah I was like this is amazing it's so
beautiful yeah
I completely agree with that feeling I
remember filming and then sending it to
our friends and going like holy [ __ ]
we live on a different [ __ ] planet at
this moment especially when you're
comparing like times to times like now
everything kind of like you know it's
getting more assimilated but I'm like
I'm like damn like these guys were early
adopters of this philosophy yeah
so that's uh so these are kind of the
small reasons that are pushing me
towards going like yo we need something
else but you wouldn't want to do it
actual Church whatever religion no you
know what we'll let you know would be I
know I have no idea I'm not there yet
I'm just will be Muslim I don't know you
could be whatever the [ __ ] you want to
be well we got to be one as a family
don't we we don't have to it's nice but
we don't have to you can do whatever you
want because I don't know khabib's
badass and I want to be whatever the
[ __ ] he is he's bad at
badass and he's [ __ ] muslim I'm like
I could be Muslim too I think yeah so um
that's that's one of the one of the
resolutions just kind of getting closer
to my spirituality when I told my mom
she was so happy and so relieved she was
like Wow because my mom's very religious
until you tell her like
what church
she doesn't care yeah yeah she doesn't
care like hey she's like your mom like
your mom's super religious and she's
just like cool you're worshiping
something I go to the Temple of Lucifer
now I go with that
I mean it has to be good
oh well not changes everything yeah
um
so that's one of them the other one like
I was saying just mainly focusing on
taika and getting him right like my
priority right now completely opposite
to your selfish ass resolutions of like
who I want to be better martial arts I
want to be a protector is that selfish
to you yeah what are you protecting if
your son's [ __ ] super sick what are
you protecting
you need to protect them against the
sickness that he's got dude yeah I'm
protecting him against the bad guys what
bad guys the bad guys are in his body
protect that
no if he's having a seizure well bad
guys and then people are trying to rob
the house I'll get the house so he can
seize peacefully
yeah but who's going to be there for his
season
you are yeah right the unselfish one I
get it you're gonna breastfeed them
right there and there and I'll have a
tear come out of my eye what the [ __ ]
it's a beautiful sight I'm telling you
um so yeah I'm just so focused on him
like right now I kind of feel like um
I haven't even watched this movie I
don't even know why I'm about to
reference this because you're done like
that I'm pretty [ __ ] up Aaron Aaron
Brockovich I think the name of the movie
is Julia Roberts yeah where she's just
like going Against All Odds in like I
think in their town they were like
poisoning the waters or something right
well she wasn't a lawyer but she started
going head-to-head with like legislators
yeah and like lawmakers I guess to like
switch and change some [ __ ] again I
haven't watched it but it feels like I'm
like this huge [ __ ] Advocate right
now for taika and I'm like you're wrong
we need to change that you need to be on
my team you [ __ ] suck let's keep it
moving let's like I feel like I'm I'm
doing that right now definitely feel
that from you and I love that fine
um but
oh oh for that reason I'm like
I can't even fathom having additional
time to do anything else until this dude
is like a hundred percent or we have
answers that we have a plan set for
until that happens I'm just like nothing
else [ __ ] matters at this point you
don't even care if I could tap you out
anytime you're not [ __ ] tapping me
out [ __ ] you're gonna be
spending all this time at the hospital
I'm gonna be [ __ ] training my ass off
and when you're done with the hospital
I'm gonna be tapping your ass out left
and right you say this [ __ ] and I
actually believe you because you are
[ __ ] weird and you would do that you
would I don't know you wouldn't be
training I've been no you haven't so you
didn't even move you didn't even see
that [ __ ] coming not because there's a
no it's no threat yeah whatever my eyes
are it's no threat when did your uh news
resolution start 1-1
23. I mean those set dates to me are
arbitrary but I do like having a um a
theme for the year yeah kind of like a
mindset like a mindset hat that I put on
you know if it just kind of like feels
good you know kind of like uh
like you know when you're training for
like
um when you're just lifting and when
you're training for a competition
like your reps and sets are probably the
same and if you're following a program
it's probably the same you [ __ ] [ __ ]
training for a competition you just have
a different hat on you know yeah you
have a different purpose well so
obviously it's like right now I'm trying
to be more financially uh independent
for our family right it's not like if I
don't have this hat I'm going to be
squandering money I'm still going to be
like Frugal and be smart with money but
now I have a goal and I also see how
beautiful you've been to want to
um help taika and treat him and and like
get him the best treatment that he can
and also even further be
um the mom that you want to be because I
really definitely think that's your
strength by seeing you be a moment no
[ __ ] you stupid [ __ ] I've been telling
you since we got together can you show
that please and so for me I want to
support you going there because
you're a way better mom than you are a
co-worker
and I'm like shut the [ __ ] up you whiny
[ __ ] I want my own office and you're
like no Mom but I like it so much well
anyways and that's so that further
drives and gives me passion to want to
make ourselves even more financially
free you know yeah yeah
that's CUNY and very not selfish of you
know obviously I'm [ __ ] teasing even
though my goals definitely sound way
more unselfish
um but I do think there's something I do
like that you're you have like your your
theme in that hat on to to still
consider that
um because I do believe in like not
manifestation but once you start
uh either uh visioning or like
um or having visions of or thinking
about it the more your brain because
your brain likes to solve problems right
so the more your brain subconsciously
tries to look for that thing so that it
aligns and and you start looking at
these opportunities when they present
themselves it's kind of like when you
get a car that you don't think anyone
has or even or even when you start even
thinking about that car yeah when you
start like thinking of that car for
example and you're like man I never see
Volkswagens well I'm on the market for
Volkswagen a red one actually and then
because now it's in your brain your
brain's looking for these things you're
like holy [ __ ] there's actually a lot of
Volkswagens that I never noticed before
and it's like well they were always
there it's just you didn't pay attention
that's how I know my dream car is truly
my dream car
are you gonna say what it is no because
people are going to buy it fine and um I
don't care it's a 67 Chevelle I've been
thinking about it for over 20 years it's
been my dream car since like you don't
see those since high school I see novas
and all the other ones I never [ __ ]
see one ever I might see one every two
or three years maybe
and I know I'm like that is my unicorn
one day I'll have one but God damn I
never see those the closest ones I see
are gonna buy some 68s some 66s but 67
Chevelle I'll tell you what if a good
deal pops up I'm emptying our [ __ ]
family
I love how you spent this podcast
talking about how
to work anymore and that I just didn't
realize how rare it was until we started
talking about it I'm like oh yeah I
don't see it so if I see one pop up
guess what
that's sayonara [ __ ] you get two jobs
for emptying it out and we're getting it
yeah now
that's not happening you're not
irresponsible like that but
yeah 20 20 23 has to be better than 2022
right
it has to be better I mean 2022 has been
pretty good I got close with my mom okay
and then I think what's really cool too
is through all types of seizures it
really
um brought us together
you know yeah like we all like have this
unified goal like it's really CUNY like
you know when we're exploring things
even us like kind of having a heart to
heart with taika which is hard because
he's five so he's dumb as [ __ ]
like
um to really help you with your seizures
we might have to start taking away like
bread I know rice oh my God yeah
udon all his favorite foods what about
dumplings no dumplings and we have to do
but this is really going to help you you
know and even for him to go
okay
you know like it really like brought us
like
it was uh because I'm also viewing it
from very optimistic point of view where
we're gonna come out of it absolutely
that's all I think about but
it it's a really good exercise that we
went through
to help us be like
team-minded and and have a a unified
Mission yeah and like just yesterday we
were in La trying to help him find a
better doctor you know and we're back do
you know what was CUNY about that what
my mom texted my brother texted your mom
they're like how is he doing our friend
and Jeremy were like how did it go and
we're like guess you know who didn't
text
he didn't text
oh my God
oh [ __ ] you're so wrong and so am I that
I know how wrong you [ __ ] are you
said it I didn't even say nothing all
right
I didn't say nothing oh [ __ ] was that
the answer yeah
you see who's fast now [ __ ]
finally yeah
yeah but but it's like a really good
exercise that really
brought us together you know it feels
like this CUNY little like Adventure
team yeah hey we need to go here
together now we're gonna do it together
you know and he packs his back his boost
she is his little his monkey Cheeto we
grab our stuff boom we're on the road
you know and he's still a kid obviously
oh how long is this gonna taste anything
forever
but we're unified you know we get there
it's like it's getting kind of late now
we need to start sleeping you know okay
okay go sleep and then like hey does it
sleep in the back seat yeah and you know
what that was too much iPad when we get
off the iPad now okay you know he's been
like not very reluctant he just
understands we have a team Mission and
we're trying to help him
and just going from place to place like
that's
um
that's that's really cool otherwise I
think it's really easy for parents
especially like us who are so deeply
involved in business that as soon as
family life is on cruise control you're
like okay how do I come back into the
business yeah to turn that up right yeah
because uh for sure it's very easy to to
do that yeah and then but for us I think
this whole thing that we've been dealing
with them it has forced us to go
business can wait like let's fix this
thing you know or even give business
more of a purpose where like we need to
do better at business so it can help
reflect into this you know yeah yeah so
I think 2022
um has been pretty cool it's been like
the most um I know but the cool comes in
different
packages you know what I mean I like my
cool one where I didn't expect it and a
bunch of good [ __ ] happens you know what
I'm saying like that's that that's a
really cool way we also got one of the
coolest dogs ever Mia that we haven't
had in [ __ ] a whole month is that
boarding school yes but we get videos of
her and she is doing awesome and she's
ours yeah and I miss her every day I
wish my mom could have been here with
her this whole time she's so [ __ ]
cute yeah but you know I think she's
gonna get we're gonna get her next week
I know we're so excited yeah yeah Ty's
gonna be so happy is it next week
or in like a weekend is it just me or
did taika feel like a little bit less
lonely when Mia was around
I think it was just you I think he was
warming up to it because it felt like
sure it felt like he was like kind of
had like his little buddy now it just
felt so cute yeah they were it was at
the cusp of that happening what if he's
and then we ripped her apart we ripped
her away from him we were like you love
her you love her don't you isn't she the
best and he's like yeah I love her so
much we're like good we're gonna send
her off for six [ __ ] weeks what if
the bed underneath taika's house is for
me oh dude
oh or the slide we just put little like
uh like groupie grips yeah so she could
like climb up there yeah dude that's uh
that's that's his little that's [ __ ]
cute you know that's exactly what's
gonna happen that [ __ ] bottom thing's
gonna be for her for sure that [ __ ] she
better if she doesn't I'ma be I'm like
this dog needs to go in the trash she's
not doing her job that way she's not
going to try we spent so much money
[ __ ] training her ass she's like a
professional okay but she's a
professional dog
all right well those were some good very
selfish New Year's resolutions that you
have
um and I hope that you at least get to
fulfill one of them
yeah like a whoop on your ass
no we're doing this together
[ __ ] if you're going I'm gonna
[ __ ] tag along you are not gonna
surpass me impossible
[ __ ] impossible you already
have way more knowledge because you've
been doing martial arts for seven years
I've never touched it once
but you're a natural say that again huh
everyone says you're natural literally
the top coaches in the world tell you
you're natural and then you tell me Shut
the [ __ ] up tell who to shut the [ __ ] up
them no I don't yeah
whatever everyone sees so much potential
any except for you
yeah well uh uh not this year all right
dude or next year that's coming up
2023 20
[ __ ] studs so 2024 we're doing Jiu
Jitsu in 2024. no I'm singing
yeah it's not my goal but I would like
to if you're gonna [ __ ] start it you
better believe my ass is going to be
there
Charlie you just wait all right vato uh
on that note do you have anything to say
good I love it thank you guys so much
for tuning in
um let us know how you feel about this
episode like the video share the video
comment on the video let us know what we
should be talking about because
um I think this guy's boring in front of
me and I never know what to talk to him
about so let us know what to talk about
in the comments and uh we'll catch you
next week thank you so much bye